okay everyone let's talk about the
post-credits scenes of ant-man in the
wasp now spoiler warning obviously if
you haven't seen the movie yet
specifically let's talk about how what
we saw in the post-credits scene could
set things up for Avengers for now uh
Sam broke down the post-credits scenes
in another video that you should
definitely go check out but just to
recap quickly the first mid-credits
scene shows Scott Lang entering the
quantum realm to gather some quantum
healing energy but then he gets trapped
in the quantum realm when hope and
probably now the post second post
credits scene is a little more
straightforward it shows Scott's empty
house with an emergency broadcast signal
on the TV and an oversized amp playing
drums that we saw in the trailer now
okay to me there are a few interesting
things to note from these scenes first
the idea that Scott is trapped in the
quantum realm how will he get out does
he have a spare Pym particle on him will
Captain Marvel so now play a role in his
rescue and actually if you're listening
closely before he went through into the
quantum tunnel Janet warned Scott not to
get trapped in a time vortex
while he's down there a time vortex and
does the quantum realms laws of physics
allow wormholes through time is that
what we're gonna be seen in Avengers 4
there's also the idea of multiple
realities now earlier in the movie
during Bill Foster's lecture on quantum
mechanics he mentions the idea of
tinkering with these kinds of physics
could cause chaos that could cause
multiple realities I'm curious to hear
you guys theories about what's next for
Scott and how these Clues could connect
to the ending of this movie to Avengers
4 he's in the current guardians of
goings right now he's great he's very
funny it's very good how do you think
he'll get there this in the video it's
like if you one time went down like want
a room by accident mm-hmm and you
happened to find an accidental way how
to get out of there and someone's like
can you go down there again he's like
yeah but I'm gonna take a bunch of the
emergency exit stuff that's cool they
weren't told him no and so he can just
go and get get
there may be yeah I'm gonna get why we
wouldn't yet know is that it might you
might not be that might not be an option
of how to get out of there like there
might the way to get out of the quantum
realm might be harder than that I don't
know he should have gone down on the
ship by the way I do think the quantum
realm is being set up as some kind of
way to defeat things and I don't think
she would have said time vortex I don't
think the writers
I don't think would have put that
in there if it didn't have an importance
later on yeah he said this is the this
is the only way or there was no other
way and we're in the endgame now I
handed over the time stone okay and an
endgame game you play games with balls
balls are similar to particles Pym
particles and then we're there and then
9/11 yeah and then Kevin Bacon yeah I
think in some ways these post-credits
scenes are more like carefully crafted
than many parts of the movies themselves
because I think fighting knows like how
critically the audience is watched those
looking for creative I feel like they
get told like here's some things you
gotta hit and then you guys still get to
write it because I think had they been a
little bit more on top of it
tonally or something they would have
realized like hey this first post credit
scene Thanos has attacked like New York
has under attack there's like war in
Wakanda with an alien invasion like a
lot of crazy stuff is going on and
they're like joking about the horn or on
the roof like that we saw the moment of
the snap not the moment when Thanos like
gets to earth I don't know they just
seem like very out of touch with what's
probably on the news well there was that
whole like timeline thing that the
Avengers defending the war post-credits
scene right like in fury and Cobie
Smulders character was hearing about
this news and then like maybe thirty
seconds later they just it seems like
there was like a delay in communication
and they're in communication I think
honestly like this that's kind of gonna
be an in world solution to a thing that
they're not nailing out of the world
we're just like how much time pass
between this and this and why did people
like sometimes not know anything about
it or sometimes spend a movies worth of
time treasure I think that's one of
these things that might be make plans
and all of a sudden you hear about a
flood somewhere it's like I'm still
gonna do the plans I think there was
like a fox news alert
I don't know why that Fox News but our
the quantum particle part like if that
actually heard about this news Mike
we've got to get around oh my god it's
all going down extra element oh yeah
like a cascading effect of like people
are like trying to like get into a good
situation before I don't know yeah I
love this emergency broadcast signal
right like that yeah it's totally set
this really interesting tone tone tone
tone Quan tone like this is the reality
we're now in yeah right it's like a
zombie apocalypse are an alien strike
two-word they don't even have television
broadcasting - yeah I think in a
previous video either that I wanted a
post-credits scene or I wanted somewhere
maybe it's beginning in the next movie
or something but exactly what that
emergency broadcasting implies which is
what happened to the infrastructure of
the world when half of the people
disappear and again it's that the show
leftovers is a whole freakin serious I
don't like 2% in the leftover yeah
exactly it's like I I'm so fascinated I
could have a whole movies worth of just
like how does the world deal with half
of the people on it are gone yeah yeah
oh it's amazing it was bad hot yeah well
I let us know down below how you think
these post-credits scenes might connect
to the opening shots of Avengers 4 are
we gonna see everything get used in a
specific way or is it some of it's just
stuff that I am I decided to like throw
in there just to set a tone but yeah as
always to subscribing the rockstars for
all of your theories and gossip about
Avengers infinity war in countless
Marvel Cinematic Universe thanks
everybody